the star-studded house of gucci is
inspired by the true story of italy's
infamous black widow who conspired to
murder her ex-husband but just how much
of the film is hollywood fiction versus
historical fact yapikai movie lovers i'm
jan and in this video i'm revealing the
biggest things that house of gucci got
wrong about the real story of patricia
reggiani and the gucci family the true
tale of patricia reggiani who came from
humble beginnings and married into the
rich and powerful guccis has plenty of
intrigue and drama however house of
gucci isn't shy about spicing things up
including patricia's wedding dress the
movie's costume designer prepared two
designs the first was modeled on the
real dress worn by patricia which
covered her all the way down to the
floor but director ridley scott opted
for an alternate design that was more
revealing and is a homage to famous
italian actress gina lola brigida
according to the film's costume cutter
even though the wedding scene was short
it was significant for the character so
the outfit had to have immediacy and
impact in the movie maurizio meets his
childhood friend paolo when he flees to
samaritans to get away from the italian
tax authorities the film plays up the
idea that his romance with paula began
while he was still with patrizia and
also that he decided to separate from
his wife while they were together in
switzerland in reality though the
details of maurizio's split with
patrizia were much different it happened
one weekend in 1985 when he told
patrizia he was going on a business trip
to florence left with a suitcase and
never came back it was left to a friend
to tell patrizia the next day that it
was actually over also in real life
maurizio didn't reunite with paula until
1990 a full five years after he left his
wife on top of that the movie completely
omits the fact that maurizio was
actually having an affair with a
different woman cherie mclachlan who
said their relationship spurred him on
to leave his unhappy marriage maurizio's
affair with mclaughlin lasted until he
met up with paula years later which did
happen in switzerland though it was
actually at a club and not on the ski
slopes i suspect the filmmakers omitted
the relationship with mclaughlin to
condense the story given the final films
already over two and a half hours long
and they chose to portray paolo over her
as that's who he's with at the time of
his death also having patrizia share
scenes with paolo ramps up the movie's
drama before the separation do you ever
steal anything paola i'm trying to teach
alessandra the importance of not
touching other people's belongings the
details surrounding habitrizia would
eventually have maurizio killed have
also been compressed and dramatized for
the movie in reality it appears patrizia
didn't meet with the people involved in
the murder as happens in the film
instead she asked lots of different
people if they'd help her then she got
her psychic friend pena to act as an
intermediary and find the assassins
there was also another person involved
who was the real getaway driver however
in the film his role has been merged
with one of the other conspirators also
in the movie the assassin shoots
maurizio three times twice in the back
and once in the chest but according to
the real-life concierge who witnessed
the murder the gunman shot maurizio a
total of four times three in the back
and a fourth time in his head this may
have been changed to make it a little
less gory in the movie and there's a
touch of extra drama in the trial with
patrizia refusing to answer to her
maiden name reggiani which in reality
she also did when signing her police
statement defiantly telling the judge to
call her senora gucci a reference to how
she continued to use the gucci name even
after her divorce and how she's
popularly known as lady gucci and like
lady gaga or lady gucci if you'd like
your own honorific title check out
established titles the sponsor of this
video established titles is a project
based on a historic scottish custom
where landowners are referred to as
leads or lords or ladies in english and
you can buy a piece of dedicated land in
scotland for as little as one square
foot which allows you to officially call
yourself a lord or lady so you can have
your own lady whistle down style title
in time for the next season of bridgeton
and with every order established titles
plants a tree to protect biodiversity in
scotland it's a new fun way to support
conservation and a great surprise gift
for your family and friends there are
even couple title packs available for
partners so you can get adjoining plots
of land you'll get an official
certificate with a crest proving your
title and a unique plot number on a
private estate in scotland you can use
your new title on credit cards plane
tickets even dating profiles plus you'll
be helping to preserve woodlands and
raise funds for charities like one tree
planted and trees for the future who
support global reforestation efforts
there's some amazing holiday deals on
title packs at the moment so visit
establishedtitles.comflix and use our
special code flicks to get an extra 10
off all purchases or tap the link in the
video description the filmmakers also
took some creative license when staging
maurizio's murder the movie's production
designer has said that the spot in milan
where the real murder took place was
draben and cinematic and they were
striving for a more heightened
atmosphere so he says they found a
section of rome with wide streets that
could credibly stand in for milan and
the area was a collage of architectural
styles gothic renaissance and arabic
that gave it a very operatic feel
the day maurizio was killed patrizia
famously wrote in her diary the single
word paradisos which in greek means
paradise in the movie however she writes
the italian version of the word paradiso
i imagine the filmmakers did this as
they thought it seemed more logical and
more people would quickly and easily
understand the italian word than the
greek one
the film team also opted for a much more
dramatic way to show how patrizia had
paola evicted from the home she'd been
sharing with maurizio in the movie
patricia turns up at the apartment and
after embracing paula tearfully orders
her to be shown out of what she now
calls her house i subscribe to
unconventional punishments back in the
real world this never happened instead
the eviction order was delivered via a
notarized letter drawn up around 11am on
the same day maurizio died just a few
hours after his death
although patrizia and maurizio's
daughter alessandra appears in the film
their second child allegra was
completely cut from the story i suspect
this was done to condense the already
long movie as even the daughter who does
appear isn't a crucial part of the
script also it means the filmmakers
could avoid casting more child actors
whose involvement in production brings
additional rules and regulations
especially as they'd already had to get
three actors to play alessandra over a
range of ages another interesting detail
absent from the final film is that after
patrizia was convicted her daughters
tried to get a retrial on the basis that
after their mother had an operation to
remove a brain tumour in 1992 she lacked
proper control over her mental faculties
at the time of the murder this did get
her sentence reduced by a few years
however since then both daughters seem
to more or less have cut ties with their
mother
when it comes to the look of the
characters although the movie's makeup
and hair team seem to have done a good
job with patrizia the real gucci family
have complained about some of the cast
claiming their depictions are
unflattering one of maurizio gucci's
cousins has said their grandfather aldo
was a lot taller than al pacino who
plays him and that pacino's overall
heavier look and sideburns compared
unfavorably to the real-life aldo who
she says was much more handsome plus she
also felt offended by jared leto's
untidy and fashionable look as paolo wow
you are gucci you need to dress the pot
after the release of the first trailer
some suggested lady gaga's accent was
more eastern european than italian and
since then francesca de martini an
italian actress who worked as a dialect
coach for salma hayek who plays pina
commented that while she was listening
to hayek's scene she thought gaga's
accent was a bit off sounding more
russian than italian i don't consider
myself to be a particularly ethical
person
but i am fair de martini also said there
are a lot of different accents in the
film with in her opinion al pacino
sounding more new york italian kochi is
what i say it is an adam driver's accent
being nearly non-existent as far as
fakes go they're pretty good at least
it's my name on the marks not yours and
then there's jared leto's paolo which
you can make your own mind up about
these are just mock-ups you picked the
real firecracker according to day
martino there wasn't a dialect coach on
set and she was only brought in at
hayek's request after the actress felt
she wasn't getting the accent quite
right don't let these forces around you
dictate who you are you are strong you
are magnificent now in lady gaga's
defense she revealed in an interview
with vogue that her method to get into
characters portraits here was very
intense she said she lived as her for a
year and a half and spoke with an accent
for nine months of that apparently never
breaking even off camera if you don't
know i'm gonna make sure you do she also
said it was impossible for her to speak
in the accent as a blonde so she
instantly dyed her hair and she added
that she worked hard on figuring out
patrizia's specific accent
and uses different ones depending on who
she's talking to in the film it's time
to take out the trash gaga began with a
dialect from vignola where patricia was
born and then moved on to what she
described as a higher class way of
speaking that would have been more
appropriate in places like milan and
florence whatever you think of the
accents though or credit goes to lady
gaga for improvising a line that's
already become iconic can you keep a
secret father son and house of gucci so
what do you think of house of gucci and
who gave the best and worst performances
let me know in the comments below if you
enjoyed this and a thumbs up and a share
are hugely appreciated and if you're a
fan of crime dramas tap left for my
latest you video with season 4 theories
about love's return or tap right for
something else you're sure to like
thanks for watching and see you next
time yippie kai movie lovers